[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
my
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on you guys uh first off i
want to say blaze is missing in action
uh i know i promoted blaze uh but he i
don't know where he is i'm sure he'll be
here somewhere
um i did see someone put hip-hop hip-hop
actually got called at the last minute
to go do something so he couldn't make
it
uh but you know we we we got uh me king
and hustle here man you know hustle got
a little blue in him so he could take
place his spot i'm wearing blue today i
got the blue headset on i got the blue
shirt
sony baby
oh man
you're so sorry
we are going to go ahead and uh hit this
off with the best we can man we're gonna
hit this off the best we can so like i
said we're here the attic show where we
talk about the past present and future
in gaming i'm here with my co-host
hustle and motivate first off we're
gonna do hustles let's
be let's do our weekly update on what
did you do on kingdom hearts
all right so
i finally figured out that i was in the
wrong palace for like
after four hours don't ask me how i
don't know i just flew to the first
thing smoking out of traverse town which
was hercules palace
i'm not supposed to be there so somebody
in the chat was like yo you got to be
level 40 in order to fight the balls
here so i looked at my my stream oh i
looked at my level i said what level am
i i'm level nine i said i'm not supposed
to be here so i hopped up in the gummy
ship and i
went to the next palace which was
tarzan's palace come to find out i'm not
supposed to be there either um
i'm gonna be picking up stuff right away
so i guess i'm a little slow i see like
the difficulty levels on the palace like
when you when you or the kingdom when
you go to him so i said oh damn
i said wait i can go to another place so
i went to the other place and the first
place that you were supposed to go to
which was the third place that i went to
i finally got there and that's a
alice in wonderland's
palace and i'm looking at the name in
the chat yo
yo
that that last person who left a comment
in the chat boy you you have to change
your name uh sir
i know you are you know one point now
anyway i'm having a good time with the
game though um
it's square
he need this super chat so he has to
read his name
we don't need the money
put that money up put that money up
i want to point out don't don't don't
let this uh don't don't let this man get
you man you you do whatever you want to
all right
i'll make it quick i'll make it quick as
far as like my my time with kingdom
hearts it's it's [ __ ] go away king no
it's fun it's super fun um it's squares
rpg i don't expect for this to be bad
however
it's showing his age
a lot showing his age a lap but i mean
you know it's just something that i can
that's something that i can overlook and
i really want to overlook that and like
play through it and everything um they
said it's recommended that it's going to
take 30 or suggested it would take 30
hours to beat i think it's going to take
me 40 because i was in the wrong place
and for whatever reason when you were in
the gummy ship i didn't know that you
could die and i keep down when i'm in
the gummy ship trying to get to the next
place so i keep dying so that's fine no
those that cop them me down in the gummy
[ __ ] that's gonna be a compilation i got
the uh solo footage and everything but
um
um
i'm reading the chat no no but i'm
having a good time with it um that
impression video was gonna go up this
week but i'm not gonna put it up this
week um
the second part of it because i'm
streaming everything on youtube the
second part of that playthrough was
going up this sunday on youtube so yeah
just be on the lookout for that and i'm
having a really good time thank you for
asking me thank you for kind of making
me keep up with this um oh yeah real
quick i got a stream schedule
every day
tuesday thursday every tuesdays and
thursdays i'm streaming every wednesdays
i'm
every wednesday i'm here and every
sunday you should get an upload
you better get an upload i'm working too
hard i'm working way too hard way too
hard that's right
my dundell i see my dundo's in the
building
yeah sorry about that guys
little boxes is going on with his joint
what oh yeah yeah i got to fix it
because blaise showed up at the last
minute
uh but i appreciate him showing up i
know he's a busy dude
the only thing i got to fix is kings
uh but you know
sorry about that but you know you know
one thing i do want to talk about real
quick
is
as far as kingdom hearts goes
uh you know i'm glad that people are
playing that like two decades later it
seems like i think two decades ago
a fair assumption
kingdom hearts has always been like that
game that people do enjoy but you don't
really see a lot of people play for and
you know i know that the the story can
be a little confusing because of how
they told to tell it
but
kingdom hearts three i felt like did a
fantastic job giving you
the
what's the one i'm looking for letting
you choose how you want to play that
game
what are you eating
it's wonderful grape you've been playing
you know when you get to hercules palace
i just see i just see
i just see some chick that looks like uh
the chick alpha laden just sitting there
picking off a grape just feeding the
king and he's just going like this
as long as you got my white face
oh i do want to i do want to point that
out too um i love the fact that the
original voice actors for all of them it
seemed like for all of the kingdoms like
they're very for everybody from disney
that's dope to me man like what sound
the likes
yeah no i think it's i think it's them
though yeah yeah either that all sound
alex you know
yeah i mean kingdom hearts is dope i
like i like i like the fact that i
always get midway through and just ditch
them
so
it's just it's just what it is you know
i'm like a squirrel
yeah so we got blaze in here man how you
doing blaze what's going on
you ain't doing very well apparently so
we're going to move on to king david
what what's going on king how is how's
life thinking
feeling kind of blue today baby oh man
oh my sony blue
ah feeling me you feeling me baby got my
sony blues on you feeling me ah
i knew my boy blazer showed up i had to
fraud a little bit with the blue baby
you know the king bleed blue
like harachi ha hayachi's little eye he
bleeds blue too
oh my god that's a dope hat i like that
i like that
a little tech show on tekken love i do
like that yeah that's that's that fan
fest bust off that's that's that's
that's what that is so i was playing um
attic is crazy because i'm playing elder
ring okay and i'm trying to get the um
the the black blade tisch
uh ash
so i had to finish my white man the
white uh white face
quest
did that
um i did all the stuff without having
the golden scarab so i had to run down
to
the golden scare go to the place of rot
went in there hit the bosses twice
killed him
grabbed a golden scare ran back out of
here i went back to my little farming
area um
but i i'm trying to get this ash and i
have to find the quest line so i'm been
looking up some guys on youtube to do
the quest line but
no but i do like my mimic uh
my mini ash but i'm gonna try this new
ash out of course
so
hey how close are you to to beat now
with the ring
i made it up to um
the city of ash
oh so you gotta burn down the tree
you've you finally beat what's his name
the dude that
that shoots the little dark energy beams
at you
oh yeah you took yeah man that dude
right there shout out to my man chris
um he came through
and that dude started working him so
i was just like you know what i'll wait
to chris get him really low then chris
getting really low then i just sit in
the background and i use the same
abilities that he's using on us he has
he uses this um ability that
when it hits you it drains you of your
health
but you have to be repeatedly hit for it
to take effect because the health will
come right back
so
you just gotta stay in the mix you gotta
stay in a fight i mean the gate the game
is
bonkers
especially how you choose to play it you
have
three bosses left
yeah yeah i'm in no hurry
now the second the second and third boss
they're a little rough
uh no actually technically you have four
bosses because the last boss is one of
those things we have to fight two times
uh i got your shield
oh you finally got my shield
i got your shield i got the thumbnail
shield the um thumb print shield i got
the thumbprint outfit
um so i could just sit there and bow
guard the whole day long and just stab
people in the stomach just be ruthless
i'm i'm me personally i'm trying to get
all my stats
to where i'm comfortable at so right now
i'm building up my arcane so i already
built my faith up to 35 i'm building up
my arcane up to 35 right now so oh that
that's what's up you can just re re-roll
if you want
nah i i i like i like how my build is
i just want to see certain weapons how
do you work because all right so hustle
if you don't know i don't know if you
deep into elder ring i'm not i'm not i
beat uh margarita never said but go
ahead okay so this um well then you know
that there's certain weapons that you
get higher tier weapons they have a
little a little red x on it and if
you're not uh proficient in what they
need to uh take that red x off they will
stay there and you won't ever see the
full potential of that weapon
so my thirst bucket behind i want to see
the potential of every weapon so i'm
just like i'm i'm not at the point where
i gotta go see who's the ball so who's
this i go clear out of area i go see if
that's the most stuff i can get in that
area i try to get all the secrets out of
that area and i will stay on the area
for like two or three days it doesn't
matter to me
uh but you know attic is a speed run
type of dude he had an end of the game
he done double ended the game he did a
review on the game
i've i've moved on from eldon ring i
don't got that type of the only time i
jump in is is when king wants me to uh
pull up pull up yeah yeah i i hit him up
yo let's do wow but okay
so you're playing on xbox okay okay yes
of course i mean wait a second wait a
second you thought i was playing on the
playstation 4 the best version of the
game
you mean no no i thought you was playing
on pc actually i don't know
ain't nothing on pc really my pc right
here high powered he dope he dope his
heel he won't ever see a game the only
game that he saw was that fallout that
that we did what was that it was not
fallout what was that game that we did
uh that you made me get on steam
uh among us
okay yeah
and that's not no graphical powerhouse
not at all
exactly it's it's good all right so you
know
blaze i don't know if he's back yet but
uh you know
whenever he has his camera's not up he
got his playstation he's he's running it
i love him i love the setting i finally
got going to where like
it's like i don't want to see my face
okay now you can see my face
yeah the auto focus thing
yeah all right so
first thing we're going to talk about i
do want to talk about the future of xbox
in the future of playstation uh
kind of redundant to do that without
blaze here so we're going to go ahead
and tackle square
enix i should have put enochs in there i
don't know why i didn't but square enix
selling the western division
oh look at that look at that
that that's a pretty impressive
background key i don't know i i don't
know about the the camera placement i've
always felt like that's a little uh nah
that's that's that's stuff for the
that's for the late night you know
it's like man
what's going on
what's up what's up i don't you know bro
i'm sick man i'm not even doing my
podcast you're lucky i like you adam
you're lucky man no you love me so
that's what i do
he was like king gonna be on i got a
shirt i could come through with my man
because my man gave up his knees when it
came when it was time for for
gran turismo and he definitely gave it
up so i got i definitely got it you know
what's funny man blaze was telling me he
he didn't see that he would say where is
that it didn't no i couldn't
super chat real quick uh from drawingtj
hi king hi guys i think microsoft needs
to get embrace your group next after
this the deal i guess will you lose some
people assuming about activision embrace
your group
ah look look here i i get it embrace
your group is like hot in the news right
now because they bought all that western
division off of square enix but uh they
don't need wes uh pressure group maybe
they would if they buy them
you want to see
how quick the ftc called ladder monopoly
yeah that's that's when they're really
gonna jump in
now they 40
more than they got a hundred right i
think no no no 40 active studios not
talking about the subdivisions how about
so yeah they got yeah now they out of
control lord of mercy
all right so we
uh wha what's going on blaze we'll get
to the super chats here in a second uh
so what what's
what you've been doing i i probably i
hate that you feel bad man
yeah
yeah it's all good i just got kids i all
my kids are home and my my baby wants to
see me my three year old he keeps
running in my room so it's just a rough
time man that's why i'm good man
let them in
enjoy it now because when they get older
they don't want to have nothing to do
with you
i know i know
that's a fact give me a second give me
oh yeah
i probably butchered that what is
whatever it is crystal dynamic devs to
their new overlords embracer i hardly uh
hardly knew her
i highly know people really are about
this embracer group five dollar
spiritual from el nino the future of
playstation is a joke look man oh man
it's
slow down we're going to talk about that
we're going to talk about whether or not
you know the new direction that they're
going uh we're gonna talk about xbox too
but let's let's jump straight into
square enix and i just noticed i didn't
put enochs in the title i'll fix that
here in a second score enoch's selling
their western division for those of you
that's been living under a rock because
i assume some of you live under a rock
square enix went out and uh we've kind
of got guesses uh for a little bit it
was
you know what the beginning of the end
was hustle when i saw
them letting crystal dynamics go work on
another person's car
[Laughter]
that was the end of the uh the end of
the the beginning of the end there
but now it's looking like not only
crystal dynamics uh the people who make
guardians of the galaxy uh what what's
that company called montreal no that's
that's yeah that's wb idols i don't know
i don't know
which i'm a huge fan of idols that's my
company like i'm not really big fan of
crystal dynamics i know a lot of people
like their games but uh idos is the one
that i like the most but they sold it to
a company called embrace your group um
i'm gonna ask you all to be honest here
did you guys even know there's a company
name embrace your group until this
happened yes
yes and i know that they were very
powerful in the way that they move um
i first started hearing about embracing
group
shortly before the microsoft um
activision thing because
i think bg said it on weapon wheel so i
just i took the time to google them and
i saw how many like companies and
studios that they own and i was like oh
my god i was like i don't think people
are going to be tripping off the
microsoft activision deal like this look
at this other company and then they were
in like the same
like i want to say the same level but i
heard about them and then like a 10 cent
like those that's another big one who
are like they kind of just
gobbling up
for le you know for lack of a better
term like all those other like studios
like they were getting them though what
what what 10 cent does
10 doesn't gobble up anything
10 cents goes and take a piece of you
drop a bag get a piece of your soul well
embrace your group looks like they to a
point they do that too embrace a group
see that's what i was talking about with
the 40 the 40 that they do own
and then they have tentacles all into
everything now when i was doing a deep
dive into um 10 cent to see exactly all
the things about tencent because they
had popped up and uh i was a movie i was
watching
and it said you know um tencent i was
like oh hold on wait a second now
they're into the movies
and
found out that the uh chinese uh company
and the government they they so strong
they lost i think how much billion they
lost that it was like what four billion
five billion something like that
um because the the chinese government
hit the stocks
and um
i was trying to tell them not to invest
in video games and stuff like that and
they didn't even phase them they
continued to work in the same uh fashion
that they was working so i saw embrace
the group and i was like well that's the
second biggest
and i'm like what the hell is going on
we are conditioned to believe
that america is the biggest baddest best
we are conditioned to believe
that uh
you know oh microsoft woke up they're
about to take over it's somebody else
that already been taking over
right under your nose and you just
didn't see it or you didn't pay any
attention to it because you think that
this is the biggest slice of the pie
where we are you can't see the forest
for the trees
10 cent embrace a group those are the
real
hustlers and movers and shakers in the
game
but the embracer group i knew about them
after doing a deep dive into 10 cent and
i feel honestly um
that the activision deal with microsoft
will go through with flying colors with
no problem because there's stuff like
this going on
and it's happening commonplace with no
problems and only hold up with this this
deal right here
is disney
is the hold up right now because the
deal didn't go through yet disney is
holding up because disney has to okay
the contracts with the of of avengers
and the guardians of the galaxy and
those are the two ips that they're going
to continue using and working with and
investing in because you know they lost
a boatload of money because of them but
ah
that's it but i do want to i do want to
say this though um
shout out to uh
homie in the chat who's i'm just gonna
read it i'm not going to say his name
but shout out to you he said isn't it
group thq nordic yes yes yes they are
yeah um
yo they got them for the low too like it
was like all the way hold on
embrace your group is thq nordic they
used to be a tsq nordic yes yeah okay so
thq nordic changed their name
what the hell did this happen
it's more than that
because remember thq nordic went and got
defunct but then they had a whole bunch
of investing money into the into the
company and
you grow from there you know from from
from from the dead bird rises to phoenix
all right so
i'm going to post this in this in the
chat for you guys and the um chat that
we have on zoom here is
like a little bit of a of a link that
uh uh on some of the stuff they buy
they bought from them so you know we'll
go over it just a little bit momentarily
uh let me go ahead and switch scenes all
right there we go i'm hoping they should
go and talk real quick
yo yes they should be able to hear you
okay that's fine all right all right so
here's what they own uh obviously i
don't know what some of these are now
legacy okay and i know that's a really
big thing and i think they could
actually cash out on that pretty easily
i love that uh they own thief which i
don't know if you guys know but i didn't
like the last thief i thought it was
okay but they it needed
you might be the only one
when they launched with the xbox one
yeah it was a launch game that was a
dope launch game for launch game come on
blaze like [ __ ] launch game that was
the dope launch it was
okay
all right did you play it on nintendo 64
king no i played it on the 3do because i
have bread oh
well i'm sorry you wasted your money
kind of no no actually i didn't i had i
had i had a dope experience with my 3do
please don't try to shame me because
they had 10 games get away from me sir
so
obviously they bought two mario which is
interesting they own the tomb raider
license does that mean they own the
movie franchise too yes
it's interesting i feel like
okay so then we got dxx uh due sex i
don't know how they want me yeah
they are sex so i got it i got it they
got a few hitters
that's a good list
this is just like without you know they
probably negotiated something with
marvel when it comes to like the
avengers and another guards
right now this is not a done deal yet
yeah so they probably did something like
that you know i would say out of all
this here
what do you think would be the first one
they hit first clearly
tomb raider but after tomb raider
because we already got clarification
that tomb raider was being bought
like like i said it came to probably be
the one that i loved
i think a lot of people haven't seen
that floating around today too the um
the avengers game didn't apparently it
didn't make a lot of money they spent
they lost 200 million
they were being clowned at every
earnings call
it was like a blight on the company and
that the guardians of the galaxy was the
last straw with them and i hear it's a
dope game so i hear it's not even like
it's not
it's not really i thought that i thought
that that was a good that's all right
visually
what game usually it's okay
guardians of the galaxy is a good game
that's what i mean that's what i meant i
i think
all right so
let's
let's talk about
them
in terms of the western market
i personally feel like this is better
for them
for all those studios because i i don't
think square enix really cared about
these people i don't think they cared
about any of these ips i think the
moment marvel flopped they were looking
to sell
it it's just like to me
you you you killed some of your
franchises you you you it kind of like
what what ea did with dead space where
it's like you want to be too much into
the development and you end up killing
what you wanted to do and you end up
killing what they can do good
so it's just like i felt like there was
a lot of that going on i personally feel
like these studios are going to flourish
better
under a new regiment like obviously we
don't know if if embrace your group is
going to properly fund these studios um
i don't that that can be up in the air
maybe that will actually hurt them more
than help them but as far as like
creative freedom as far as like where
these studios can go i honestly feel
like it's better that this happened than
not happen because i'm coming i'm a chq
addict you know i mean i'm not going to
call them like that sounds like a place
so is there official name thq nordic
has always been in financial trouble
like they put great games and they put
out such they put out games at a high
rate too like they they drop a lot of
games at one point i kept seeing thq thq
north but um i hope man i look at we
need more of these
double a companies that's the problem we
got big triple a games indie games but
there's not that in between like game
that comes out of nowhere that like
surprises people anymore it's like it's
like either big or just and that's it
that's because how the marketing is
skewed yeah the market in the skew to um
the the indie games
uh
they get light if they're in a streaming
service right and the big market games
is they're already budgeted so they're
going to get most of the headlines and
all the coverage is uh for these guys
looking to get the big games the like
you said the double a games they don't
get any coverage they fall in the middle
of the gaps and you just be happy to so
on pick up a game or you see a game in a
service and you're like oh let me try
this and it's like wow this is really
good why wasn't this pushed
the market in dollars aren't there for
games that you have questions about
because the stakes are so high right now
right so uh the avenues are different
too
they're looking at people like you
myself uh other um youtubers influencers
to like a game
stream the game and hopefully the game
takes off right word of mouth right
right so
this is the point where we're at right
now
um they'll fund the big game
the indie games will be on the service
and the service will provide that and
then those double a games
will grab it and then we'll talk about
it so that's that's how jose is right
now it sucks but
i actually feel like
people don't understand how much like
people oh it costs a lot of money to
make games it does but you know what
cost the majority of the money to make
games it costs a lot of money to market
games
and that's where a big portion of the
budget go to these like big aaa
expensive games they're probably
spending just as much as it costs to
make the game if not more to market the
game like you know when you see
something especially when you see
something like monday night football or
you see something on like the super bowl
people don't understand
that's millions of dollars
for for not even a lot of that time like
when i worked at dish network
we always was like you could clearly see
the trends and stuff now it's not as
easy as it used to be to market it on
regular you know your your like mom and
pop shows like shows that aren't that
big uh they're not really valued and i
would say probably 70 60 percent of tv
isn't easily marketable anymore got to
be the walking deads you got to be the
monday night footballs you got to be
because a lot of these shows have moved
on to the netflix where it's online uh
that's where a lot of the biggest
bulk of shows that are going is these
other online services and for the most
part they're not on any type of you know
tv
ad revenue thing i mean i heard netflix
is making a
uh uh ad
service where you can pay less to have
uh ads in your and i think that's that's
bogus i've always hated that if i pay
you for subscription companies do that
i'm not trying to see ads i'm sorry if i
pay you for a subscription service
i will pay extra for no ads i will you
know
people that's the reason why though yeah
they got to give you the option to
appeal to all of these other services
competition at a lower yeah
it's just
showing you like
do it here yeah what what they'll do is
they won't they won't advertise the
regular price anymore they'll advertise
that price for the for the ads so now it
doesn't look netflix is 15 a month or
whatever it is these days now it's like
netflix is back to ten dollars a month
but uh but and what they won't they'll
put like in little words at the bottom
of the advertisement but we having ads
on like in little tiny words that you
have to like zoom in to look at it it
doesn't be fair bro all these companies
are being finessed at the same time yeah
they're over charging and they're
expensive but when you think about bro
on my netflix account period like i got
four or five dudes in the community on
the same account and you know we eat off
that one account so yeah it's 15 a month
but also four people from different
parts of the world are you utilizing
that account right now and like even
with you know playstation you know if
you game share on xbox or your game
share you if you don't game share you're
[ __ ] i mean
you're crazy
language sir language well first of all
first of all i didn't say
mentally deficient
you see there's a there's a difference
when you see somebody driving down the
wrong way of the street you're gonna say
man he's [ __ ]
i'm not talking about what you're
talking about i'm talking about the hood
version of that so we ain't even gonna
go there acting like i'm talking about
something else we talking about people
are acting out of character and if you
don't have a certain feature like blaze
says
that is out of order you are out of
order sir yeah it's
i know it's one of those things um i'm
watching the halo series and i'm not
going to hold you
i feel like i want to put some i like
that show don't let's not do that let's
not let's not even go there let's not i
like it a lot i need to i need my own
see
if i ever did emails like iop does
like iop it's pretty much like an
everyone to come together you know you
say something that takes off you make an
emo for it
if i ever did emails on the attic show
no one else is getting opinions on it
that's gonna be my emotes if i wanna
come out and say some crazy stuff when
when hustle says something off the wall
like he likes the halo tv show it's
going to be my emote that's like you
wrong but it's oh man well no no but i
got no i got i got thoughts on it no no
we're paramount what they do and i hate
it like the fact that i'm paying for a
service and they have ads there that you
cannot skip whatsoever if it was like a
youtube thing the way you can just like
go in the you know lower hand left hand
corner corner and say skip ads cool i
probably wouldn't mind it as much but i
got to sit through all them i got to sit
the commercials for a service that i'm
paying for
whether it's five ten dollars a month
whatever like it don't matter like i
don't like the fact that it's there i
actually wouldn't mind because sometimes
hulu will will give you the option
before an episode yo let me put all the
ads in once in one go and you can watch
all the ads in one time and the rest of
the shows uninterrupted if they would
get more options like that i wouldn't
hate like ads so much but you don't
really get options like that and you
know what really gets on my nerves too
king i don't know if you've ever seen it
when you're watching a streaming service
that you're not that you're paying for
the no ads version of it right and they
advertise their own [ __ ]
it's like yo just because you
advertising your own stuff that still
advertises i don't want to see it
you know what i don't like
that the ones that are ad free oh that
is the highest bit rate ones that's the
4k
extra extra bells and whistle one uh
you can get the sub rate you know
substandard the visual one with the ads
you can get that for the nine dollars
i'm like first of all right off the rip
i got to do the the highest quality one
and then you know the ads you know what
hbo max does i'm really pissed off with
that i gotta shout this out
i'm watching peace uh peacekeeper is it
is it peace peacekeeper peacemaker
peacekeeper was a good show i really
yeah peacekeeper is it's mentally out
there
yeah that's that thing you know what's
crazy that man was born to be
peacekeeper like he he does it right
well john cena yeah i always like when
people leave their little field like uh
like leave their little box
they leave wrestling
john cena's a good actor is that what we
were doing i feel exactly what we're
trying to do john cena is good at being
john cena like as far as like being a
different character that you wouldn't
normally like your personality like he's
good at being him himself in a show that
the character resembles some of his
personality tears but like as far as
like
as far as like you know um um denzel
washington like these are uh you know uh
i actually like edward norton too uh
these are
actors that could be anyone especially
like johnny depp like they can literally
be anyone that you ask them to be
and johnny depp being the defendant
right now
all i'm saying is you know hey
he's good at playing
oh man but we what we want to consider
is him and i think he's more intelligent
than than what we're giving him credit
for yeah it's kind of crazy how
how he's handling that that situation
like oh i'm not even talking about
johnny depp no more uh
yeah
yeah i don't walk away from
but you know back to you know talking
about embrace your group whatever you
guys want to call them i i feel like
it's good um you know definitely go to
an embrace your group you hear 300
million dollars
on a name it's embracer
i don't care
embrace them
you gotta embrace the love they they
they spent 300 million dollars on that
on that western now
i did see another they bought some they
took some debt from them too that was
part of the agreement yeah they had to
pay that off yeah i'm curious how much
that that was a lot of money i'm curious
how much that debt was like it's 200
million is that all
i don't know but i'm willing to bet you
i i'm literally
squid drop kicked him out the door
was like you could take you could take
these people squares like you could take
these people but you need to just go
ahead you need to take all they mess-ups
too they cost us 400 million in the last
five years you could take that too
oh my god that's that's wild bread first
and foremost you know she can't cook get
out of here i was going to ask y'all was
that true in that because they said they
spent like 600 million or something like
that for the for the avengers game and
it's not they said it's not performing
oh no they they they spent a lot of
money and i even was told that the
guards of the galaxy underperformed
it's just like it's it's funny but i
want to kind of like reward this
especially the abilities i want to ask
blaze this place
um it's weird what square enix is doing
they're getting rid of all their western
division all of a sudden
uh you know i i feel like you know you
might do this before you sell yourself
to another company
uh do you think it's do you think it's a
possibility that you know baby
playstation
uh by square enix in the next year
very nice gonna not inform you man
pony up blaze go you you sure they make
the j rpg
square enix can give me nothing i want
there's nothing i want from square
nothing a fraud alarm fraud alert so you
don't
actually question it blaze
pick up that final
did you pick up that final fantasy we
make seven sir did not i don't like
final fantasy wow okay so this is my i
did then the four alerts on myself
because let me tell you something
i honestly believe sony and squares in
the in in
okay sony does a lot of um things that
they shouldn't do
like um
companies that they've been dating that
has been exclusively dating them they
buy them
makes no sense
but i don't know i guess they get
paranoid and out of fear
they purchase them right okay whatever
square has been lining up the majority
of their games for sony
square just unloaded a whole bunch of
stuff that
was the debt that was probably holding
back the purchase
from
them to go to sony so if somebody else
buys this western division that they
don't care about anyway
and remember
sony is a uh
uh eastern
company
once the western company is out
the debt is taken care of they're more
palatable to be purchased and they're
they're they're cheaper price too so i
think yeah i think they i think they get
purchased i honestly feel like king i
don't know if you agree with this i feel
like they got rid of the western market
because square enix has been wanting to
be bought by sony for a while and i feel
like
i feel like sony might have like
entertained that fact at one point in
time in the past and they were just like
yo we don't like the price point you
guys are asking we don't really need
that western market
if
if i got a side chick right if i got two
side chicks and i'm clapping her cheeks
whenever i want why why the f can i
swear why the hell would i
okay why the hell would i
go get this
i can't help i swear i why would i go
get this girl and bring her with me like
why would i make her my girlfriend when
i'm already clapping that it's the same
thing with sony and insomniac like they
were already in bed with someone yeah
they were already in bread with square
there's no reason to purchase them
because they're gonna be loyal to regard
the reason it is is
you don't know what kind of state these
companies are going to be in in a couple
years from now you don't know what kind
of state they are they might be very
open but some people will sit there and
they tell you everything going on in a
life but they don't tell you about the
three people looking for them like and
it's like it's like me and king go to
the mall right and we see a pair of
sneakers and king's like oh those
sneakers are nice i'm like yeah those
sneakers are really nice but i know in
the back of my head like damn king got a
lot of money so let me go ahead and buy
these shoes
before i keep buying them you can box
it's like sony sony's paranoid they feel
like they have to keep
i don't say i don't yeah paranoid is a
good word but i feel like
this is the new this is the new game
like yo buying buying up studios that's
like the new game nowadays i think i
think what it is too is
they know it's like you said at any time
we know playstation 5s are out there you
know you can get them
but the the demand isn't that
the demand is way higher than the supply
so you see one you know you could
probably get one in six months but
you're gonna buy that now because you
know someone else about to come up here
and snatch that playstation if you
popped up into a walmart and you want in
a playstation you see that playstation
there you you're gonna buy that
immediately because you know there's
probably someone literally coming right
now to pick up that playstation i i
think with the um
with the insomniac deal
uh after they made that game for xbox
and they they they had them do you know
the spider-man game they said we got to
lock them up
uh type of thing
and you know they brought them for the
low low anyway gang what it's the best
deal in game in history like 230 220
million bro the the value that you get
from insomniac bro is crazy the value
and the amount of games they put out at
a high quality
that's the that's a robbery
no not really because you got to see um
[Music]
you got to see the level of freedom sony
is giving them and what what does it
really entail i think that that
that within itself see the plans with
jim the plans with jim is totally
different than what anybody else is
seeing
right the plans with jim
jim already laid out the road map to
these people before they even purchased
so
the purchase price didn't have to go
above and beyond because he already
explained what the road map is going to
be
soon
the playstation is going to be a app
um
and
all the games of service and stuff like
that i wouldn't be surprised if
spider-man comes out and doesn't have
some type of online component that's
always reoccurring and always generating
some type of money i know people who say
that that that won't happen and will be
far-fetched but if they just told you
that they have uh like 10 to 25 games
that are games of service
in development what are these games
right and if you can use some of your
great ips to tack on this type of thing
and it doesn't have to be something
that's uh intrusive it could be
something that's very uh scalable season
passes
to certain things they do that now for a
lot of games they give you a season pass
you're like wow why does this game have
a season pass
is to keep reoccurring dollars going
into the game and don't be surprised if
spider-man 2 doesn't launch with a
season pass to it that gives you new
suits new missions and stop calling it
dlc
and just start giving you a season pass
to keep you engaged with the game keep
you coming back every tuesday where they
drop different missions and stuff like
that so
it's gonna happen now i disagree king
out then they're gonna bastardize the um
spider-man like you think it's
bastardizing
no no it definitely is it definitely is
if they if they add that type of
component why because it let's just say
it doesn't work for you
but it's working for somebody like me
it's not gonna work for you yeah but
dusty is not bastardized that's right
this is what i'm saying like
what what doesn't what doesn't work for
you but if they do deliver your single
player experience but also has a season
pass for the multiplayer online aspect
of the game
that caters to everybody okay to see you
the caterers to the casual and they
cater to the multiplayer dude so across
the board the game continues to generate
cash this is what i'm trying to i'm
trying to to to bring you into the mind
of jim if you're looking what
playstation is doing
actually they're starting to take steps
in that direction to bring more people
in because
124 million is not enough
and he's sick and tired of hitting the
ceiling and not reaching past the
ceiling the ceiling has to be broken
and i know it sucks to say it for a lot
of people because it it interjects fair
because they think the quality of the
game is going to suck at some point in
time if they're worried about too many
uh components
i don't believe so i believe insomnia i
can still deliver that same spider-man
experience but also capitalize on
everybody else that wants to enjoy the
game in some form or fashion i disagree
but hold on add it before you do that
use me excuse me
king
hold up the front of the front alert
light you got to hold that up right
shout out to me because i believe this
to everybody who thought um crystal
dynamics was going to be bought by
microsoft oh yeah i was going to do that
too i fell into that
if you want to get technical uh i'm
about to get to the super chat in a
minute guys i appreciate your patience
i feel like there's still a chance they
might end up with crystal dynamics but i
feel like
if perfect dart comes out and it hits
i feel like embrace your group whatever
you guys want to call them we'll have a
lot of leverage to sell microsoft that
studio to help with future projects for
probably the price of the entire deal
they just made today
so
you know i think
because here's the thing i feel like
embracer group would sell that long
before
score enix would sell that i feel like
there's a reason square enix is getting
rid of the western division i'm sick and
tired of this activision deal
yeah but don't worry so it's about to be
over they're about to set up no no no
the reason why okay
the reason why i'm i'm sick and tired of
this activision deal because this studio
this these this
particular western studio from square
fits in microsoft's whale house all
those games that we saw there fits in
there that's the single player story
driven narrative game and legacy of kane
fits in there i i honestly believe if
that activision deal wasn't on the table
being they would have organized that
they would have brought them and i and
and it sucks that this deal is holding
up everything
and it's like everybody else free to do
stuff it's like king they they're like
yo microsoft they they're kind of in
trouble by bit uh by uncle sam a little
bit so it's like not in trouble but like
they they're they're in a line trying to
get into the club and there's a faster
line to get in the club and everyone's
taking the faster life i'll give you
something better at it you ever been
driving down the highway and then you
see a car you see the police car and the
lights is on and you're like yo let me
slow down a little bit but they already
got somebody pulled over
[Laughter]
they can't get back they ain't about to
stop what they're doing to come get you
right exactly but i got a question
though because i saw some other stuff
floating online isn't playstation
affected too because they just bought a
bungee full nah three-point have many
billion
activism that hold them up a little too
activision changes the culture of gaming
buying that changes the whole landscape
buying bungee doesn't really do anything
in the long scheme unless you know even
if they made destiny
an exclusive and they just pulled
everything off of xbox and steam and
they made everything that's still one to
two games and even though destiny is a
huge colossal titan in the industry it
doesn't even remotely touch
the uh call of duty and it doesn't even
i would say destiny doesn't even
remotely touch overwatch
so you know
that overwatch has its own con which you
know destiny does too but i mean call of
duty and overwatch are both trash games
so oh man i i get that but you know
i the only thing that
i'm skeptical when it comes to this sony
if sony does buy square enix is like let
them continue their little titles even
if it's exclusive for playstation like i
liked uh bravery default i liked uh
triangle strategy like i want those
games to continue and i feel like if
sony doesn't green light those games
then that that's a wrap like we're not
gonna say why can't why can't these
dudes have multiple consoles why are you
why are you married thank you blaze
thank you
yo you listen i'll be damned if i missed
the next gears of war because i like my
box better than your box like are you
out of your mind looking i prefer
playstation exclusives but i'm never i i
need my xbox i need my nintendo as dead
as that [ __ ] is and i need i need my
playstation i just prefer
exclusive doesn't mean i i dude you guys
need to
grow up man i think yeah please
it's economics bro
if you can't afford it because you got
money and you know things are tight
i don't bla
people have an entire generation to get
consoles they can easily get one last in
last year at the like the last couple
years of the generation like the last
four or five you can buy an xbox one and
a ps4 what for like a hundred and fifty
two hundred dollars on black friday old
system i'm talking about that at that
time i'm talking about at that time
you can easily get those systems mad
cheap right now it's a different story
you can't even find half these consoles
in the stores so i understand now but
towards the
like the middle of the generation
they're so accessible so cheap you can
easily get them these people what it is
is these people they they they put their
foot in the ground and they say
this is what i stand by
this is what i'm gonna
what i'm going to defend this entire
generation i don't think it has anything
to do with money i really don't think it
has everything to do with tribalism and
and
finances all right because let me tell
you something i i came from dirt poor so
i know uh one person sharing a
playstation and everybody sitting around
that i understand exactly what that is
and that's absolute finances so he bet
his life on that playstation when he
went inside that store all right and if
that xbox take off who got tears in
their eyes they do all right so the fact
of the matter is it's in some in some
areas in some situations it boils down
to the absolute finances because these
dudes is eating ramen noodles that's the
week that they was like you know what
i'm gonna have to eat these potato chips
for the whole week until i get paid but
i gotta get places
that's real [ __ ] man i've been there
definitely been there all right so
everybody i respect them
but also at the same time you are
rooting for this horse to win i'm i used
to working off track bet at security
i've seen a dude walk in with his last
dollars
bet on his horse and he thought that
horse was going to win
but that horse lost and i see the tears
in his eyes as he he's spending rent
money because he thought he was going to
get it come up and he got a a good tip
that's like the same dude if could you
imagine you just brought your
playstation 5 and you're going home and
you open it they said microsoft just a
quiet activision call of duty
like we
we might talk a lot oh you know there's
this like weird stigma that people will
wait for a platform people are like oh
they'll wait for a playstation 5 until
they're available to get one my girl
literally asked me because she's been
using my playstation 5 uh because we
play like minecraft and stuff and and i
told her i was like well she's smart she
got a shoe well no let let me fit let me
finish because you're about to you about
to talk real sideways to her in a second
so i'm sitting there like well you can't
get a playstation 5. they're not really
vaguely open like that and she was like
oh well can i get an xbox series x i'm
like they're a little bit easier to get
but you know if you if you really tried
you could find one and she bought an a
series x she we got to go pick it up on
the 10th so it's just like you know
people aren't waiting for these consoles
it's never hard to find too like we got
to stop with that like i i like i see
pictures on twitter with bunch of xboxes
look
in boston massachusetts i've not seen
that xbox series x or playstation 5 out
in a while yeah i still have well bro
my only reason she was able to find one
is because it was best buy where you had
to like physically go there to pick it
up but it's just like look like you know
uh one thing i i'm gonna say real quick
what before i read these super chats you
guys would be thinking how you want to
answer this
theoretically because i i do feel like
some microsoft would be very aggressive
especially with all these openings on
stuff going on if they were able to but
because of the activision thing they're
they they're kind of like let me put my
my head in the sand i'm not seeing
nothing and
imagine if that activision deal were to
fall through do you think microsoft
would just that okay
you you tell us we can't buy activision
and then they just spend that money
they're supposed to spend on activision
on other things so we'll go around that
here in a second we got a two dollar
super chat from
from 108 dragon tv uh hi guys what's up
108
no
attic is hi guys hi guys you know what
that is right
that's come on that's pax
man you go in the house
hi guys
we got the fight
007 does the value of a deal affect
other companies
values like warner brothers games does
the value
hold on wait a second time out a second
hold on a second sorry to mess up the
super chat
blaze you in boston
i dude i know
oh sir wait wait wait wait
i was in boston and you didn't see me
hold on i was gonna bring that up you
didn't what the hell
yo i was gonna pull up i see when i seen
you with a cup in your hand drinking
when hip-hop gamer was there i was i was
legit jealous i'm like damn i could have
been there with the homies drinking and
chilling i swear to god and i will not
make that mistake next year i'll be
there
that's all
right all right
so he said does the value of the deal
affect other companies values like
warner brothers games i think what he's
trying to say is if you keep buying up
all of the hot stuff is it going to make
the other hot stuff their value go up
because they're like the last people in
line i don't know i don't know how that
goes i don't know if just because you
buy something like activision does that
make ea more expensive to buy be i think
it would and not necessarily on how much
they cost i think it would on how much
they feel they're worth like if you see
people buying you around i feel like you
would feel like you can get that kind of
money that's not how companies are
bought and so
bought and sold by the stock prices well
i know that i'm saying performance i'm
saying because companies are normally
bought if it's if it's you know public
companies are bought like a 20 30
percent spike on whatever their current
share or oh is open i'm saying like if
they buy activities
yeah if if they buy activision for 20 30
more
right i feel like everyone would be like
well our stock has to be 20 30 more and
i don't know if that's like a blanket
statement where everyone gets that or
some people depending on what you can
give
but you got to also uh
okay say first of all when you get these
ips from activision you already know
those ips is going to give a heavy
return off investment
expediently
right especially if you know how to
market it properly the call of duty
itself the overwatch itself too all that
stuff right there speaks for itself and
speaks volumes
not all companies do have that they can
give you a projected bungie showed
that this is what we made in a six to
ten period year period of time
this is what we're worth and this is
what we bring to the table they needed
their infrastructure for their online
stuff so i think they paid a premium on
that part but they looked at the return
off of investment destiny's still a cash
cow yeah yeah definitely
uh so then we got a
well let me make sure i got that yeah
we got a dollar super chat from let me
make sure yeah evo
uh his name is hero evo anyone who eats
mac and cheese with a spoon drinks from
a sippy cup may the [ __ ] be with you you
guys are ridiculous like that the amount
what cog and maddie started with this
mac and cheese thing is the dumbest
stuff i've ever seen on the internet but
for some reason it's like a domino
effect
what is that i can zoom in on my um got
some croc
but this right now
is my star wars crocs may the force be
with you did you got vader on them right
there boy
yes
fire fire fire
y'all got it
y'all got it it's just funny
i personally feel like your mac and
cheese can be whatever the hell you want
to if you want to eat that out of the
cup eat that out of the cup stop letting
these people bull you and you're
thinking you have to eat it
he's eating that watered down mac and
cheese we don't do that over here
we got velveeta on deck baby
baby
when he's he's sitting here throwing
water in his joint get out of here
i i'll just say this the macaroni and
cheese that i eat can not be
eaten with a spoon man like anything
they don't get regular it's not no i was
i saw people posting there's a lot of
cheese there's a lot of cheese i'm
saying there's a lot a lot of yeah a
whole lot of cheesy shots we black blood
i mean well hold on please you're not
black
right now i'm black from the waist down
watch yourself
i don't need to know that we're gonna
leave that over there
but but if you turn that mic off and you
listen to blaze talk
that's why when people saw your face
after they heard your avatar and saw
your face i was like get the hell out of
here that's not blaze
yes
coolest white
you know what's funny
for some reason i know i know he gonna
get real upset when i say this i thought
slow-mo was white for the longest time i
thought big cloud was like
i thought big cloud was way too i hate
y'all no no no no no see it did that
sucks man that's you know what that
comes from where we come from that's the
project stuff for me you know anytime i
talk proper you know
you're acting white excuse you excuse
you no i'm i'm i'm in a situation where
you know you have to use some form of
etiquette going inside the situation
i'll talk to you hood when i get back my
dude but
um that was so mad
you guys are completely hijacked it i
see i always assume that um blaze i
always thought jewish light scam i'm
gonna keep it right i'm keeping trail
with you he thought she was great
i didn't know what was going on i had no
idea uh slo-mo slo-mo was another one
like when i was doing skype because i'm
like oh oh okay i didn't know he was
okay my fault my fault slo-mo yeah
my bad bro all right so we got a
two-dollar super drift from uh adobe ray
i probably butchered that we're gonna
move past that my dude a uh iop has be
hyped for tomb raider game on game pass
like a frowny face uh we'll see we'll
see you think that you think the next
tomb raider has any chance to be in game
past day and date
uh if microsoft put that that braid up i
did want to say uh king i wanted to
piggyback off your point real quick um
that would have been perfect for
microsoft to get crystal dynamics
because they need in my opinion they
need a lot more third-person games they
got a lot of first-person stuff a whole
lot of it yeah but playstation needs a
lot of first-person [ __ ] yeah yeah i
know i know they're working on it no
they i mean
playstation under gym
is addressing their deficiencies
and they're addressing it very
efficiently
king
they're putting out
boring games like horizon when you have
killzone oh man hold on hold on hold on
i gotta shut that down
uh we we uh we will be talking about
xbox and playstation momentarily i'm
gonna get to the super chat so we can
move on okay
uh that we got a uh 13 months uh 13
month uh chat from uh
sentimento x initiative
no no no no it's seafood
what a 10 billion purchase of embrace
your grip be justified i don't want the
buying the price group i'm going to be
road to you i don't want them
that's not enough
like i'm gonna keep it a buck with you
10 billion not enough
you're gonna have to get more money up
to get embrace a group 10 billion not
enough don't walk to that house with
light pockets uh um
so we got a five dollar super drive from
flame
blaze the ps5 is too big to fit in my
house
and i can't afford to move sir let's
keep
our third party publishing
public our third party publishers please
so apparently i mean you get used to it
i mean we got a five we got a a 35 super
chat from horizon herbs i don't know
what currency that is i'm not
zar do you guys know what currency that
is i don't know i'm kind of curious
that's kind of currency that is though
i'm gonna check that actually google it
uh why would i fork out another 12k for
a ps5 for one game we get heavily taxed
here in south africa and cool with my
series oh that tells you right there yes
well okay
yeah no no that's south african money
that's south american money
no i googled it just now is 65
for every one of their dollars it's 65
american 65 cent u.s
what does he mean by one game what do
you mean all right if you're on
playstation you'd rather have one game
than none game you know what i mean i'm
just saying okay we're getting into that
okay we're going to get into that we got
a five dollars here from
king
king you got a vader statue i'm elevated
to the rank of
valedia eater with a fork oh no that's
that different type of uh chi uh
macaroni cheese statue no i don't have a
veda statue um i'm a sif assassin i'm a
dolph morphine
uh if you haven't seen any of my stuff
um there's no other you know um star
wars
up in here other than uh sith lord
uh you know dolphin also is an assassin
is what it is let's get look what do you
guys want to do first xbox or
playstation you know let's say the best
for last place
none of them but we got to do xbox last
let's save the best
future of playstation blaze how do you
feel about the future of playstation and
where you think they're going in what
direction
i think their little
their little uh embarrassing three-tier
system is just not enough i
i'm gonna be completely real with you oh
you know what i mean it's like they left
out look it
that whole tier system i just want to
speak on that i think it was
pointless other than the rebranding of
playstation now because it has a bad
bad taste everybody's most i understand
that to play psp games that's cool but
they you know they didn't introduce vita
nope you look it man
look it i keep saying this you know what
i played last night for three hours
fight night champions on my series x
okay the fact that i can stick in my
game my 360 game
it's just it's still never like it blows
my mind like yo i would love to play
kills on one two resistance one two and
three
on my ps5 at a better resolution and the
better frame rate look
i look it i might have downplayed it
then but look at wait no these games
don't come like these games are taking
longer and longer and longer to come out
they're getting bigger bigger budgets
these big aaa games they take on time
so to have a look at the fact that i got
to keep my ps3 plugged in still to play
these games when i want to play them is
just i don't mind it right because it
brings it holds value to my ps3 in my
collection but
god man you can't
you can't tell me that a guy on the
internet that can have a ps3 emulator
running kill zone 2 at 4k
and but sony can't figure the [ __ ] out
and they made the console you know what
i mean it's just
look if
my thing is sony's will be all right you
know god will drop their gains will come
out everything will be cool they just i
think they really need to address some
things um
because again i think x but in a
situation where you know the narrative
hasn't changed they got all these
studios but really we haven't seen the
effects of it yet and once these things
start rolling out i'm just keeping it
real once these wolfensteins and the
dooms and all this [ __ ] starts coming
yeah yeah no no i'm just hey bro i'm i'm
keeping it real kicking your partner
once once the game starts coming out for
xbox then sony will if sony hasn't
matched them because i don't think
once these xbox games come out the new
gears all this [ __ ] drops and sony's
coming out with these one two three
games a year
i don't know if they're going to be able
to keep up honestly i agree with you i i
do feel like
as far as output as long as microsoft
makes sure that these studios are
putting out not even like high quality
stuff just good games like well they did
high quality last year so you you get
what i'm saying what i'm saying so you
know so king we're gonna let you go last
uh hustle and motivation
where where do you see the future
cool down man what what type of guess
guess love is this can you go and land
you're going live you're going live
hustling where is
where is the future of playstation going
to you
i mean
look we saw what happened with the ps3
and how everything turned around right
for me for me personally i think things
will turn around once we see another
uncharted once we see like the new ips
that jay raymond got in the store i
think things will turn around it just
right now it just looks as bad because
playstation isn't the media darling at
the moment um nintendo's getting a whole
lot of burning press right xbox stick
you know overcoming the media darling
slowly but surely but playstation man to
you know borrow a character's name from
a movie life it's like they can't hit
right it seemed like at this moment they
can't hit right hey look i lied
it's like listen listen i love my
playstation 5 right
i love the fact that i can play the old
games on it but blaze you brought up a
good point you know i like the retro
stuff and the fact that you can't play
the ps3 games on it
everything else yeah but you can't play
the ps3 stuff on it that's that's a
glaring omission um friend of the show
kw fang uh who's playing resistance he
has submitted that game play the weapon
wheel
and like the fact that somebody made
this emulator and playstation can't do
something like that the me is just
always going to see that go sit right to
me
look but here's what i'll say of course
you can turn it around but um
i say i don't want to call for nobody to
lose a job i just feel like some
leadership changes might
those leadership changes might come come
soon if if xbox keeps continuing to
dominate like this
ship changes i mean you know jim you
know hey okay
he might have to i just got to give you
a rebuttal really quickly
and i want you to check my man jim's
resume
while we're going down this town down
this game king no no time out okay
let's let's
let's go down this path really quickly
all right jim got in position what
happened he drops down the price in the
playstation now and the playstation
ecosystem spikes go up because it was
stagnant for years jim gets in position
he automatically consolidates to the
european sector they start actually
making money they trim the dead weight
jim gets in position he gets rid of the
japan the division that wasn't making
any money and puts them into productive
areas right
in jim's defense the playstation 4 is
the highest grossing selling playstation
in playstation history
so under jim's leadership they have
expanded they have purchased bungie they
have purchased other studios they have
done this stuff under jim's watch under
his two legends in his great eye and
financially they're in the best
positions they have ever been because
they're talking about being on pc they
expanded their reach they suspended
their demographic and they expanded
their wallets
the board don't hear you sir
board here's money jim is doing a
fantastic job
now
i know sometimes it may hurt some people
that certain games aren't out at this
certain time go ahead you know
playstations in the store right now
they're doing well
they doing well sir i'm i'm just saying
i'm just sorry i just had to rebut that
part because i think jim
is the person they need
so so what you're saying is that that
that's not the person that wants the
person they need no there's the person
they need because the person that they
had in position before was putting them
in the deficit they was always looked at
as it's only going to be sold is sony
going to be sold
nobody was talking
listen let me let me tell you something
when you when you have the stocks and
you have
the only division that is actually
pushing dollars is the playstation yeah
i was making them the most money and my
tv is slightly behind you know the tvs
took a huge dip
and they were looking at cost
effectively
what was the best exit strategy in
selling this brand
how they can make
when i'm telling you netflix and google
and these other companies amazons is
looking to then they can gobble them up
easily
those things is being realistically
talked about jim came in jim is a money
man jim fixed the bottom line you would
have never saw them spend three billion
dollars on nothing
i i'll just say this you know
i don't think it's going to last forever
no granted no he's nobody last forever
well no no i feel i feel it but i feel
like you know jim ryan he has done a lot
of things you know a lot of things from
my benefit too because king you know i
game on pc you know this
i get there i can't wait to learn y'all
to come to pc because i'm who did that
for you hey jim yeah yeah
yeah he definitely he's throwing games
on pc but so i feel like playstation
i feel like playstation's kind of like
losing their essence a little bit and
losing their identity sure hey yoshida
man like he he's been i want to say
demoted but he kind of has been demoted
to like the head of indies which is
which is fine let's show how you see
that we know that he cares a little bit
my thing with jim ryan is like no he
don't son don't yeah you can make bread
but if you don't really care people
going to see that and it's
look in one way shape form or fashion
it's going to take effect in them aaa
games i mean
i just hope like hell it don't
i just hope we don't get like a
diametric situation that's that's all
i'm saying and i say we i just hope
playstation doesn't get a better type
situation yes sir the truth tyler did
put up a good point in the chat he said
jim ryan gave you bungie
uh fire sprite blue point nexus haven
house marquee he's got a point there jim
ryan under jim ryan's uh
i think you can actually give him sonya
too so under his leadership
insomniac too yeah i think you i think
he looked it up
i thought that still happened no ps4 go
check it out man all right i'll take a
look
jim was down man
i did a video on that for the record um
yeah let's go you know and tell me being
the most consistent studio and wouldn't
that but you know i don't want i don't
want to derail this too much y'all sure
that wasn't under charlatan i don't
believe so i believe at that point in
time sean was just a puppet to the
situation oh man jim was always there
ready to kick him to the side
paul shaw
he was waiting soon
let me get these super chats real quick
so we got a super chat uh 35 czar from
horizon herbs
yes it's expensive here and i am talking
about final fantasy so i think he was
talking about final fantasy in that
particular point
uh then we got a two dollar strip chart
from hero avo dang addict tree outs man
i i don't i don't know what he means by
that
um
oh yeah get those get those get those
dudes they're selling they're selling
stuff in the streets
so
king
we know that you have you're a very
vocal person about where playstation's
going to be
uh at the end of the generation uh so
what this generation okay so where where
do you think their future goes by the
end of this generation
an app
an app okay
there's no playstation 6.
[Music]
okay i can't keep learning you're wrong
okay
listen
we'll put a bet too listen listen
it's okay
i'll take it let me let me let me map it
out for you let me map it up for you
before you start getting crazy so like
king finishes well everything goes nuts
right then blaze
nuts and blaze can talk after king
all right so
i'm betting on technology i'm not
betting on sony to fail i'm betting on
technology
all right so technology is at a point
right now
where we can actually run games at a
higher resolution at 60 frames per
second in a browser
stadia showed you that stadium showed
you the actual future stadia just didn't
know
how to implement a good strategy and get
it to you see it always takes one to
break it
in order for the others to see
and implement and capitalize on it the
technology is actually available
to use for sale
so
i'm betting on technology i'm betting on
sony
and i'm betting on the person that's in
charge knowing that how much money they
lose in research and development
if they were just
making controllers
and the controllers were going out and
they were able to have the app on a tv
and they was able to pull it up what do
you interface with do you interface with
a playstation hardware you interface
with the controller
you as the human being i will go around
the room and ask each and every last one
of you
how do you enter how do you interact
with your playstation yeah it'll be the
controller but we're right the game
being run from you know okay
you do you really give a hell if your
game was wrong
yeah no i don't care as long as if the
game runs if there's no input
right there's no resolution drops and
stuff not that then we're good let's
okay so all right so this is this look
at the look at where where where i'm
talking from
right i'm talking from technology from a
technological standpoint
that i believe that this this generation
is going to last 10 years the fact that
we was pushed back because of covet is
not going to be its normal five to eight
year you know cycle we are still
two years into this launch cycle of
these consoles and we still haven't seen
the benefit of these consoles we're not
going to see the benefit of these
consoles until year three
that's right with that so i'll get a pro
and then we're gonna get a pro too
no it might even be year four with the
pandemic right you can
so will you you look this is this is
where i'm talking about technology comes
in the technological leaps that we will
see will be bounds
in the data transferring aspect of it
remember we're at 5g right now
so what geo we're going to be at by the
time that the end of this cycle is what
would this generation is we will be at
8g will be at 9g what g will we be at at
that period of time right because cell
phones are considerably more powerful
than that little switch that you have in
your house
so that is a viable option right okay
they will be in the hardware business in
the controller
the tvs will have the apps
yo the pcs will have the apps
all you need to do is take your
controller and your controller
interfaces exactly where you at
throw your headset on and there you go
see because let me tell you something
they could sell a whole boatload of
controllers right now they could have
got you a whole boatload of playstation
5 controllers if the app was just the
only thing that you needed and they
didn't have to worry about the silicon
being pirated and being picked up and
being taken by all these other people
and not in the hands of the consumer
then they can charge you recurring money
see a lot of these people are still
stuck
on the collector aspect of things or
like to have my stacks
i like to have my face yeah but you
should know that more than anybody you
should know that more than anybody
listen
and i actually know more than everybody
when i had 500 uh xbox games and 500
playstation 2 games
they're gone
i understand it i mean you know king i
agree with you i agree with you a lot of
i really don't disagree
with the majority of whole conversation
i do think there'll be an app i do think
everything you said i think you're
absolutely correct on that but i i just
think there'll be an option for you to
buy physical hardware as well like
gaming like gaming is just different
when it comes to like how we how we
consume media with like movies and like
i do think that'll be there time blaze
no i think you're right i think they'll
build an app like you said in the
controller you hook it up to the tv or
your computer but i also think they'll
have a
you know some sort of hardware that you
can buy i think
i don't know and the hardware that you
will buy will be a local ruku stick or
something like that that would be
plugging aside right i i honestly
and i'm telling you like from a
technological standpoint i've been there
at the genesis
of all of this stuff happening i've been
there from pong
it took me
you say what 45 years
to get to the point now
where games i'm downloading them
instantly off of online i'm playing them
so again the state of playstation is
very healthy it's very good they have a
lot of games that people are worrying
about and wanting to get they have a lot
of playstation fives that people want to
get their hands on their streaming
system is in its infancy and the
streaming system when it comes out it uh
well
the service system when it comes out is
going to be in its infancy they will
build on it the same way xbox build on
game pass when game pass came out it was
a joke everybody was calling it bare
bones a place where games go to die and
all this other stuff they don't have
anything there now it's the biggest
greatest thing in gaming narrative
change yeah right so
you're going to give them some time for
them to get that up to speed
but when the technological
aspects reach the vision
and you let's say you can really take
out two to three billion dollars offer
research and development uh product
placement and all this other stuff off
the table and you are just making
revenue
not to mention how much more money you
can spend on game development
that's it's right there yeah all that
[ __ ] makes sense and i'm telling you and
i'm telling you it's just not
playstation
i say the same thing for xbox
yeah but we ain't there yet i guess
that's that's the point that i want to
make and yes
i think 20 years i'm thinking 20 years
because we yo you got to understand
people still got five
kb
what's it kb ps whatever they still got
that type of internet in the midwest in
america
and you got to understand that the
actual infrastructure everybody know
like i'm lucky enough to have fiber
internet everybody don't got that yeah
and bro they gotta reconstruct
underground and put up all new [ __ ] for
that to even be viable all right
what's up okay so i finished your
statement
i just said there's a lot to go into
that i just i just want to say this
right
when elon musk
told you all about tesla
people doubted and said it would never
happen
when elon musk
told you about space
people doubted and said it was never
going to happen not now a lifetime
in our lifetime the technological leaps
have made it possible
yeah that now you can take a tesla
from here to boston on a single charge
and not even drive it drives itself
there it goes
this man has
broke and changed things
we have to change our thinking and let
go of old dogmas and see where the
technological aspects are going did
anybody see this yes ces
we have dabbled in there we have
refrigerators with better tvs than
people having a living room oh man
let let me okay here's how i think
playstation i'm no i don't agree with
king in terms of you know
there'd be a roku stick or whatever you
wanted i can't remember exactly how you
announced it here's three
here's the reason i don't think that is
because
let me talk about right now right now i
feel like playstation for the next
couple years they're gonna try to build
a
a core community
of free-to-play games uh i don't think
they're gonna like abandon
the
their single-player market whatsoever
but i do feel like
if
they're all successful or at least half
of them are
i'm curious to see how they manage all
of it
if free-to-play games are making
vastly amount more money than stuff like
god of war
uh you know the next ri uh the next
horizon type of games i'm curious to see
if sony continues to invest a hundred
percent of that kind of money into a
project that they know over here you can
invest that kind of money and make
probably another zero on on it uh you
know we got to see how sony handles huge
success in the
the free-to-play market or you know
games as a service in general we have to
see
that because how they react to that kind
of news
it will determine how they would handle
that kind of those kind of franchises
here going forward i don't think they
would abandon it but i do think that you
know sony's always been very good at
giving
people new ips and making sure people
have creative control over to doing
stuff it's going to be interesting to
see if they continue to do that or try
to push more of their companies to like
a free-to-play type of service or a
games as a service in general it just
depends how much money they make now as
far as like the future 10 years goes now
we do have that technology now but the
problem is
the internet infrastructure isn't where
it needs to be to maintain that kind of
service sure something could change in
the next couple years but unless
the government comes in and starts
helping these
studio helping these internet companies
and stuff
like you know drastically
start
building more fiber optic poles start
building more of this infrastructure to
give more people fiber octave i don't
see it becoming something that's a
mainstream thing now i do think that
what king is saying is going to happen
maybe even in this generation but i
don't think it's going to be for the
masses and it's never going to take up
the masses because until that internet
infrastructure is fixed
we're not going to be able to there's
people in in texas that don't even have
access to internet and if they have
access to the internet wow it's horrible
and they're not playing on no
playstation 5 and no series x
uh
right
but but there's a reason why people buy
the best graphics cards i'm not trying
to sacrifice my resolution i want to
play at the highest resolution at the
best yo like stadia gets a lot of credit
and it does work i played assassin's
creed i played a bunch of games i was
impressed but you know when they were
saying oh fork it's uh it's 4k native
look i got a program that tells me when
resolution is dropping it was
yeah of course but it was still
impressive you know and again
playstation now people don't give a
credit but that [ __ ] launched in 2014
and the fact that i was even though it
ran like dogs you know i mean i was able
to play a ps3 stream
on a tv it was just weird it was like
damn like this is actually working like
i see what you're saying i see what
you're saying king that technology has
moved forward so much and like just when
we least expect it if you know i mean
they they make another
but um i think they'll still be hardware
i just you know in a traditional console
i don't know technology can move as
forward as it wants
but it's not really about where
technology is it's about the
accessibility of that technology right
if it's not accessible then it's
pointless it has to be anywhere you can
get a cell phone tower you're going to
be i agree 5gs is going to change things
especially
if you can have another
pandemic and um have everybody locked in
the house while they work and you you
don't know and then you pop up and now
you got 5g anyway conspiracy theory um
if we go through that again king not now
okay okay
you know what
i know this that's the best
like i i i i'm gonna learn a lesson
before they believe it right you
understand like i've i don't put past
anything past anything right i say the
world is full of huge possibilities and
stuff like that and i actually see it in
that manner i actually can see all of
this stuff literally because i've been
on this planet long enough to actually
seen wow that's some crazy stuff it
really did they they really did that
thing i've actually really seen
when they put an ethernet card and
nobody had a uh broadband
you understand
but they put it there
i actually saw when they put a hard
drive in the xbox and they was like what
are you putting that in there for you
just raising up the price
but then it starts clicking into the
game
it's going to be a point in time
where
the games are so expensive
to make
what is taking away from the the
facility that it's just one point i
wanted to say
unreal engine 5
software right
if you go back to see unreal engine one
or unreal
engine two or unreal engine three y'all
look at it you'll see the huge
difference right and five right
leaps generations bounds very minor
stuff
to make everything run more efficiently
with the online component
the test bed for unreal engine 5
is fortnite
it's not a single player game
it's not a story driven game
it's a multiplayer
drop in 100 people and a last man
standing game
that is the test bed for that technology
look where we're going to know where
we're going to get to
i do feel like when it comes to
playstation they're in a good place
we have to see how they handle
game pass with all the games coming out
how they handle that we have to see how
the games as a service games come out we
have to see how they handle that success
because
i honestly feel like if sony ever gets
the games as a service that that hits
like
like a fortnight or something
they're not gonna be the same company at
that point but you know we'll have to
see how those those games do uh one
thing that i do want to point out is
as far as the hardware and what goes on
i think
what's going to determine where the
hardware goes in the future
is how
mobile app streaming apps is gonna
happen uh xcloud you know services like
that because if those start to be
successful
companies are gonna invest more money to
make that as accessible as possible and
if you start seeing xcloud being
successful in like you know uh areas in
japan china you're going to see
microsoft wanting to double down on that
type of technology and with that type of
technology you're going to be able to
eventually leak that to
these little roku sticks and the reason
they would have a roku stickers up is
because they're going to want
the best receiver on those roku sticks
to have the best because let's be right
here
wi-fi is the main way people connect
devices so they're gonna have to find a
good way of connecting wi-fi
to that so they can have as least
frequency interruptions as possible and
you know it's like uh afroprong said in
the um in the chat data caps will still
be an issue and i agree with that i have
a data cab now all of a sudden haven't
had a data cap in years now i have a
data cap i don't know why but you know
it's very curious to how this goes
i'm curious how the gaming industry in
general is going to change we're seeing
a lot of consolidation going on we're
where publishers are buying uh you know
comp uh developers publishing publishers
in general like microsoft by
inactivation you got sony buying bungie
curious to see out at the end of the
generation how that landscape is gonna
look so you know
just real quick because we still gotta
get to the xbox thing i'm not trying to
keep you guys here all day but just real
quick by the end of this generation
who do you think is going to be aligned
with sony by the end of the generation
as far as them bought something like you
know a ubisoft or something like that
what company do you think is going to be
part of their organization by the end of
this generation we'll start with king
first thank you for the fun
allowing me to okay
first
um square
square i think i think they've purchased
square
um and a couple of uh indie uh studios
um it would be great if they ever picked
up devolver digital but um
uh yoshida i don't think he has a voice
anymore so i don't think that happens um
so yeah
i will honestly just bet
on
square because i think square can get
those games of service that uh sony's
looking for
uh and also still deliver
some story
driven type of stuff that they that
they're known for they're going to keep
that little piece of their self there
but they're going to get to the point
where majority of the games is going to
be games of service um
they're trying to monetize everything i
i uh what about you blaze who do you
think is going to be on the sony side in
terms of mike sony buying them by the
end of this generation
ah man i don't know
i'll just say to be different i'll say
capcom god i
you let me go first next time go ahead
blaze go all right i don't know that's
it all right
you know what i mean it's
it's like the second i don't know
hustle it makes sense
companies are still going to be all
right like we got to stop acting like
these call how's this company doing like
both companies are doing great nintendo
is doing great even though i think you
know they they need a new random you
know i think they're going to need a lot
more all right what about you hustle
who's gonna be on playstation side
well i was gonna go with capcom but
you know i mean because that's that is
the obvious choice that's that's like
the next obvious choice for people
online um
i don't know if you would consider them
because king you had said uh devolver
digital right yeah i was i was also
thinking uh that emu because you know
that emote like like the volvo digital
great they have a great alpha talent in
terms of like well in terms of beat em
ups first right um with the volvo
digital in general they have a good
alpha challenge for everything that
they've released so i mean if somebody
is next on that list i would i would
have said that any move but i mean
that's just that's like a super small
purchase you know i didn't want to say
this about all the acquisitions uh
i think it was called moriarty shout out
to him
um
i think it was like
a lot of
smaller companies are pretty much just
going to come up
out of uh like we see a lot of people
getting purchased we shouldn't really
worry about that because new triple a
triple a
no new uh new indie companies they're
gonna come up out of nowhere and just
rise up and take over i think i heard
that on like sacred symbols or something
but
i agree with that point um but now i'm
gonna say that emo right um let's see
who else i think he has a personal stake
in making that comment
i mean what yeah he got a game all right
yeah yeah right this guy's got so yeah
no i don't believe no indie games are
just gonna no indie companies yeah i
don't think any games are going to be
able to come in and take over
i can't see i can't see indie developers
like establishing a better indie field
where studio a publisher such as like
devolver digital
team 17 where they can advance their
stuff to a triple a product teams right
well i guess they won't but uh let's see
uh sega right like i don't think anybody
would purchase sega at this point
i'm not really sure because like you
know that was a that's the sonic movie
making too much money boy yeah
the price of the brick definitely is
crazy they went up and went up they they
earned in their own and they keep so
they should have got in before they made
their first sonic movie yeah
now now it depends on how this does on
the sonic the new sonic collection the
new one that's out not this one this is
why i'm glad i still have this um it
depends on how
how that does and the next sonic game
does in terms of whether they'll be
purchasing that but i would i would say
sonic for real um
oh i'll say sonic i would say sega will
probably just make a lot more sense
it was just a game that he was playing
he uh
he post he held something up so i just
held up something i got from pax it's
like no okay here he is again that he
likes it
yeah yeah but i mean i think
sega would probably because you know
capcom was
was my pick but i would say sega um you
know what hell since we're talking to
the hypotheticals rockstar you know what
yeah say you're just going back to
farming
all right all right all right so let me
get the let me get this super chat real
quick and we're gonna move on to xbox uh
so we got a two dollar super chat from
uh
don del rey and sonic was under leighton
for 229 million
so i think he's saying king uh you're
fraud that it wasn't the right i told
you he was a puppet he's a problem okay
we'll move on
all right so king you are starting first
where do you see xbox being by the end
of this generation the direction they're
going go
number one
number one
are we talking about market value or are
we talking we're talking about market
value where's my public siren hold on
let me find my place yeah you want this
you want to use this no i think he wants
a legit police iron okay you can call
the police on me because it's gonna be
highway robbery when you see it happen
um
they they're they're moving on
way too many cylinders right now
see it was good
when
they were weren't like oh that's cool i
like that that's cool as the viable
option
uh for microsoft
you know when when microsoft didn't look
over and say oh you know that's that's
the little one over there he doing his
thing or whatever
no right now
they they're the microsoft themselves is
betting heavy on this
as you can tell by the purchases you
know
uh 44 billion and then you know 60 68
billion
um
the acquisitions that they're putting in
place
and they should be right they should be
number one we're financially with one of
the biggest companies
in the world as your as your your home
your parent company they should be they
should be in first place they they
should be laughed at even having sony in
first place over them and financially
there's no comparison right so
yeah this is what i'm
i'm just talking about facts you know
you have that much money you should be
able to buy first place right
nice all right so that's what they're
doing
so when you go on you buy bethesda and
you you shore up the whole western rpg
market all right that's unlocked all
right now i'm buying obsidian i'm doing
this i'm doing that i'm making these
moves i'm doing this i'm doing that okay
we put the service out there and they
take their lumps and they bruises all
the time with the game pass and the game
pass is starting to make moves now
now these these dudes at 32 million oh
man all right they're making moves now
without these other companies showing
you the hardware the games yet
you have the most powerful hardware in
the business out right now
you have the most cost effective
hardware in the business right now
so right now well you can't buy a series
x or playstation five you can go get s
and a lot of these dudes like you said
have subpar internet or
have subpar tcl television right well
look who works
with those tvs
right so financially from that aspect
you're hitting it from that part this is
the first time microsoft has been
bowling on all cylinders the acquisition
of active vision automatically makes
them something to be terrified of to be
feared
only two other companies embrace a group
and uh tencent
can rival them in the studios that they
have at the disposal
so these games are going to start coming
out they're going to start hitting where
do you see them by but again i'ma tell
you this
they will be a app as well
so just to clarify you're saying that
they won't have a box either
no i don't know why would they why
they'll be the first ones to get rid of
it we keep no the first one to get rid
of is going to be sony
all right all right king all right
and the reason why i'm saying that is
you there's no need for you to take a
loss
there's absolutely no need but this is
forget sony segment this is xbox segment
they already been researching the roku
sticks
they've been researching
that hundred dollar banger
these chips are getting smaller
if you didn't have a screen on your
phone
and your phone just ran off the chips
your phone is powerful enough to run
your games that you're playing right now
let's keep it a buck
i don't know about that
i don't know what phone you got but i
know what phone i have really man you
know you know i got iphone 11 max but
you're right you know let me se let's
let me tell you if you wasn't worrying
about the resolution on the screen and
you wasn't worrying about anything else
and you're worrying about just the chips
and stuff you do you really think that
it can run breath in a while too
man this joint will blow up in my all
right
yeah hold up let's be real he's got an
old integra but no but let's be real
here
breath of the wild doesn't even run on
the switch that good yeah
for a while sure though that's so evil
you made you made really good points but
look as far as microsoft will finish
i'd say number two i think they do
overtake playstation even with games
like uncharted which i love even you
know last week oh you said nintendo's
still up there i don't even talk to
those boys
listen yeah get out of here i don't even
talk to those dudes i got them let me
talk but let me explain let me explain
why though yeah
y'all got to understand and blaze you
you know you will still have a console
y'all got to understand how many kids
love mario i got the little
bastard wait is there i got him over
there in the background
he been moving up he'd be sneaking up on
you two kings i know he's saying
well that's what i'm saying but like
y'all gotta understand like nintendo's
gonna like forever be
top top top tier and only not because of
the titles per se but because of their
titles but we're not metroid not because
we don't know my mentor but because of
mario because of mario kart because uh
splatoons
look at my son he brought me some food
man i saw oh
that's dope
thank you all right i haven't seen him
in the background but that's my point
that's exactly see right right on cue
look look at me watch me be great
station fans fake games oh my god oh man
all right so hold on let's roll back a
little bit
um we're gonna let's go to hustle hustle
where do you see the microsoft and xbox
brand being by the end of this
generation
end of this generation they're number
two um because number one
who's number one
nintendo will probably be number one if
we if we're really being real i think
they do surpass playstation but because
they they're on the roll they xbox is on
a roll and like i said
they're going to have like when they
title start hitting if they titles
really hit and they're consistently
hitting
90 plus metacritic you know i don't
really care about metacritic but if they
if they're up there in quality and you
know if there's a quote new quality if
perfect dog uh you know whatever of a
vowel right i think that's the name of
it if all them games if all them new
joints hit and they really hit and game
page really takes off at like say 50 60
million users on a consistent basis then
i don't see how they could actually lose
two playstation these these these these
videos you're not deleting this podcast
right this one
yeah so i'm just saying but
and i say all i have to say is i say all
i have to say this i still think
nintendo will probably come out no more
i think nintendo because you know and i
only say that because you got to
understand what a switch is right now
switch over 100 million right now when
they release the super switch or
whatever they call the next generation
switch yeah that's what they're probably
going to call it that but
once they release that and this
if it's the same thing with a suitable
version of the current switch now and
the switch oled now
then nintendo probably won't work oh
that's super switch won't even be as
powerful as a ps4 mark my words that's
super sweet
50 million 30 million they when it comes
to first party games the attachment rate
is crazy we understand this but look a
lot of people buy switches because
they're curious because they think they
want to play a game on the go and they
think they want to but bro i got three
switches some dude said oh you think
nintendo's dead cause you're not a real
gamer buddy you're probably a nintendo
fan and i probably got triple the amount
of games in you and just let don't even
go there with me by the way look i would
play this nintendo
if they could actually increase their
power value and i don't mean to sound
power but dude i'm not gonna play a
third party game on the switch why would
i ever do that so now you're just
talking about first party right so if if
kirby's land don't appeal to me right i
bought the last mario party
but but if some of these disney world
games don't appeal to me kirby like i'm
never gonna hey so it's just look it
i don't know man
kirby kirby lit by the way but no my
point is my point is
everybody has children my point is no
matter how old we get and we might want
the power narrative of course i do of
course i want a traditional console
however
hey look man
yes sir just to clarify you're saying
that
xbox is going to be playstation now can
you give the reasons why you think that
well i did i did um it's it's mainly
because of i mean maybe that's that
nostalgia kicking in for me but i mean
when i see stuff like a mario odyssey
when i see mario come on well they're
talking
about nintendo talking about why you
particularly think that xbox would be
able to gain more market share than
playstation well i had brought up the uh
the fact that i bought a game pass which
is you know do you think that
you think that value is going to help
them the most okay i think that value
will help them tremendously um do you
agree with that blaze
no yeah let me get this up because my
kids are at my door name
that's why look it i don't also i don't
know if you understand this but and i'm
not taking that's an xbox but i am oh
you're fine
three generations in a row
it's metal there you go here's your
sticker put on your shirt okay
playstation is pop culture bro whether
you like it or not it's just the cool
thing to have even my son he comes home
oh dad nobody likes xbox
nobody likes xbox guess what but things
are starting to change little by little
because yesterday my son's like oh dad
can i use your xbox for what he's like i
want to take your xbox in the room i
like what do you need that for he's like
oh cause
xbox don't got roblox i'm like what
playstation i mean he's like
playstations roblox so i couldn't
believe that like
uh
that now he wants an xbox to play these
games that you know their big deal like
if microsoft was if microsoft was a
bully they could have took minecraft
like you want to talk about big games
microsoft wanted to whether you like
minecraft or not bro they really wanted
to pull that under the rug
that would have been
money
yeah yeah we get it it's a money
that's why jim ryan fits just like you
say bro but look it i think playstation
won't lose their spot in terms of uh
being looked at whether they're there
with sales or not i think oh you're
talking about the
the figurative number one yeah the
figure okay not the actual number one oh
yeah but no
more no but no no but they're not xboxes
man they've been take they've been
overtaking them for the last three
months
the beginning that's because you can't
buy a ps5 huh you can buy a ps5 because
you can't buy a series x don't make no
excuses yeah you can't get okay wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
slow down slow
yeah i i understand that there is a lot
of people that would like to get a
playstation 5 but it's not in stock
but i feel like a lot of people are
acting like everyone that wants a
playstation 5 at this exact moment is
such an overwhelming amount of numbers
that like to me
if you look at like the statistics
they're about outselling their previous
ones do you think they're gonna double
that every month
like i feel like a lot of the people
that want playstation 5s they got
playstation 5s a lot of the people that
want xbox series x's they got xbox
series x's now there might be a lot of
people that are going to buy one in the
future are going to buy one when a
certain game comes out they're not
really looking but i do think the people
that are willing to invest right now
on these platforms
they have them now sure there's a
percentage of them yeah there is a
percentage of people that are looking
for them but the way people act like the
percentage of people that want them is
so large and they just can't get them
and i don't believe that i do think that
there's probably a good amount of people
out there looking but i don't think it's
going to be this giant
adjustment to what they currently are
selling now sure they might sell an
extra 50 000 a week maybe but i don't
think people really act like they're
going to double their sales the moment
these are
you know
i still think playstation outsells xbox
you know why i know there's to be a lot
let me tell you why
the majority of the people got a
playstation 4 last generation because it
was a hundred dollars cheaper
x oh that's big
little man
is 200 cheaper right
bruh
bruh they're being wrong they don't know
they don't know anybody the broke dude
when air day
every day in the hood you know and
you're right
so until they right
together in the price point factor i
don't care what nobody say this is why i
can say that like the proposition of the
xbox series s and that game pass
together that's an unbeatable
combination it's cheap and got mad games
get me in that's a casual consumer yeah
and that's all that matters i guess yes
which i got i got a fear about that that
type of thing but i don't want to go off
on my i know physical game tangent like
i normally would do
it's over i don't like that bro i love
y'all i gotta go though please i love
y'all i gotta go i don't feel that my
kids are like knocking at my door i
can't i can't keep them bless you my
brother
i do appreciate you appreciate it and i
did give you your needs for your grant
to miserable you you called it right
even though the game is half baked but
eight by a couple days i got you that's
it i almost lost two yeah you almost did
it
i respected i'm just upset that the game
wasn't what i wanted it to be because
honestly i know be honest with you i was
gonna actually dust off my playstation
and play that game i was really looking
forward to that game
so yeah i just wanted to addict thank
you brother i appreciate it hustling
coming on man indeed indeed
we're happy we had today
yo
yo
i'll be on one of them shows though
attic on iron boards whatever the one it
is uh well i want probably
the but does the i would like you to i
would like because i know obviously
playstation doesn't they haven't
announced theirs i would like you on
both if you can if you can make it both
of the reactions because what i like is
the just the
dynamic between you and king on these
reactions like he what's funny is i give
it up to blaze because a lot of
playstation fans would not jump on a
live stream with king doing these things
so right there uh
there's uh the um i think that's a big
cloud on too big clouding
so i'm not there to belittle my brother
so that's there's never nothing like
that
that's that he he got love for real
general love right here in my heart for
him there's a little bit of dude's got
to understand
i just want to say this like
we're just sparring around like who can
like if he wants to say playstation's
ass bro i don't that doesn't mean i
don't love this guy i don't don't have
respect to him i don't give away
playstation's assets as whatever don't
they don't listen man you guys take this
[ __ ] too far sometimes look if he says
sony baby and this [ __ ] is whack hey
that's his opinion he can say whatever's
whack i still i still got love for the
man just like he said though i
appreciate that yeah
and there there's a little bit of a
spoiler thing yes uh we are going to
have blaze 4k on the reaction for the
xbox show and uh most likely they're a
big cloud is going to be there too but
blaze is going to be there and hopefully
he'll be able to come back for the
playstation because what i like about it
is king gives him that smoke for that
xbox when they do oh he gets creative
and then and then when it flips flops
around
blaze gonna give him that smoke for the
playstation you believe that ain't it
blood
you know you know you know i i i want to
i want to get my hats off because when
we watched that whack playstation
conference last year the year before i
can't remember which one
is it
by the end of that show blaze was
filling us he's like this wasn't it and
then blaze lee's talks to his
playstation fans that net that day the
same day on the park as i heard blade be
like yo it was good it was really good
i'm like that's not what the energy you
was throwing out the perception is great
yo
yo because perception is great yo but
you know what king was right about that
show the console reveal absolutely saved
the show like that's what i said i told
you that yeah yeah that's a fact
but you know they're like blaze what are
you talking about the show was great i'm
like bro i was at the iron lord she's
like oh so like you know because
if you sit around yo if you sit around
in a group and all you hear is trash
trash trash you're gonna leave that
[ __ ] like damn
yeah
that's kind of weak though but that the
the reveal
saved everything for me it backs at
least for me
all right so i appreciate you coming
through uh thank you
appreciate it yes sir
later
we appreciate it oh man it's almost 7
o'clock
here so we got seven
super chat from wolf of darkness amazing
podcast king we need it every week
and we got a
uh a 17 super chat from wolf of darkness
gamers will start selling their ps5s in
2023 no one can resist xbox upcoming
exclusives there's more than 60 plus
games in development for xbox all right
so
um you know clearly i like the super
chat you know this is how i think xbox
is going to happen i think xbox is going
to hit the cloud gaming very hard
i think they're going to make sure that
it's accessible as everywhere they're
going to try to get into more
into more markets than they have i feel
like they're going to double down on a
lot of these studios i don't think
they're done buying stuff even after
activision i personally feel like
they're going to go for a japanese
outlet which is sega uh if they don't
buy they're gonna have a really close
relationship with them like their games
come to game pass day and date i think
they're going to try their hardest this
generation to set up next generation for
more of a world wide appeal not
necessarily just in america and
everywhere else just sprinkles i think
they want to start next generation with
a lot more going for them in terms of
how they're going to be perceived in the
entire world and not just a couple
parts of the uh the world i think
microsoft's in a good point right now
they're in a good situation where as
long as they play their cards right and
they don't drop the ball too many times
because they can drop the ball with
certain games not every game has to come
out and be a a hit but they got to make
sure the big ones come out and they do
they do good
bigger question how long you think this
generation lasts how many years
20 26 20 27
how many years total
six seven
okay
we're already two down
two down yes we got another four or five
years well how long do you think hustle
generation gonna last
i mean if they do the same thing they
did last year king i think you said it
earlier like ten years if they do like a
playstation five pro xbox series x pro
and all that if they do that then yeah
this is
what this they wouldn't be cool for xbox
because they got that series s
and i think that they just if they do
that they just continue that and they
make the x the base running in the pro i
think they do that type of thing but if
i had the gas if i really had to guess
on it
i would say eight years considering the
situation
the current
real life situations that we're in with
the pandemic and i don't know if we're
in a recession than that but like there
we go yeah your things are tight things
are tight so this one may go a little
bit longer than like ps3 generation so
hustle um
let
real quick question like alex on the
playstation by the end of this
generation
who do you think's going to be aligned
with xbox go go go go hustle first who
you think's xbox going by then what's
crazy about the playstation one is that
was kind of up in the air we didn't know
i don't it could be anyone with xbox so
who do you think
microsoft would have bought by the end
of this generation man who's who's left
like
i don't know uh if i had to just
say a big one ea if i'd really had the
yeah what do you what did you
okay well true gamer just hit me
playstation invested in accubite a
platform that enables developers to
build scale and operate live service
games
like i said
this is the last playstation
oh man
get over it get into what i'm saying um
the xbox oh ubisoft ubisoft yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah ubisoft is next if y'all
if y'all think i'm joking that's the
next target that's the next one they're
gonna take down and if ubisoft is off
that table ea roll over it's in that's
it because they need another giant
publisher that has a great production
arm and great ips if it's not ubisoft
it's ea but it's ubisoft they're going
to take down ubisoft because ubisoft
makes the games that they want inside
their service that keeps generating
revenue
true gamer good-looking brother
i think that they're going to
buy sega i think that's who they're
going to have
i think they're going to have a lot of
smaller studios by then i think what
they're up to like what 34 right now
that's how many students
yes that's including activision
yes i think by the time they finish this
they'll have 50 plus by the finished
generation jesus i think that's pretty
fair don't you think king 50 plus
studios
after activision and um ubisoft yeah
well i don't know about ubisoft but you
know i think they i think they'll buy
one more big publisher um i don't think
they'll be they're definitely gonna be
as big as like activision but they're
gonna be a well-known publisher and i
think they're gonna buy studios uh
individually and place them with the uh
the publishers uh so that's pretty much
the whole show now i do want to point
out
next week
we're going to have all the attic shows
xbox prediction show
um so you know it's gonna be me and
hustle and
three to four other people uh it's only
gonna be one topic there's only one
topic that's the xbox comments go ahead
king i'm trying to i've got to be
serious
three to four people i don't know yet um
i think forte gaming forte is gonna be
one of them i'll give you guys that
uh i will be announcing the other ones
i will be announcing the other ones at
the iron lords podcast this sunday at 1
pm
uh so definitely show up to that if you
want to get a little uh
little inside information well it's not
inside i'm the inside so clearly you can
get a little information i'm gonna try
to
shock some people with some of the
people i don't know yet and the
negotiations part so we will be having
our xbox press uh prediction show next
week uh i don't know if it's gonna be
five uh five or six i'm not to talk to
hustle see get a good thing that vibes
with everyone and the week after that
we're gonna have the playstation one
uh so
pretty much how ilp is going the other
direction they're gonna have uh i think
they're do we're doing in a nintendo
show i ain't doing a nintendo show ain't
happening uh so we're going to do the
opposite direction uh then i hope he's
going to do the the the playstation one
the xbox one
we're doing it the other way around
because i want and plus i'm not gonna
have a lord on any of these prediction
shows because i don't want to take away
from the iop one if you want their
prediction on these
conferences you're going to have to go
to their the iron channel for them
and and another thing
i'm going to stay away from guests that
we're having on iop during those weeks
as well so uh you know i want it to be a
different show different vibe different
show but i appreciate it for coming out
king where can people find you you're
doing this this combat talk
tell them tell the people about what's
going on there man catch me on saturday
nights with a little mimosas and drinks
and some stuff banging out at 10 p.m we
got canelo versus bivou oh it's gonna be
dope uh just pull up check it out have
some fun i just uh hit up my boy uh
working on overlays uh it's gonna be a
call-in show soon so you guys gonna be
able to call in live you're gonna have
my phone number you're king i'm talking
to you on the phone i'm like for real
what you're drinking you'll be like ah
and i'll be like
but listen
pull up
if you don't got nobody to hang out or
watch the fight with or anybody just
chill and talk to i'm that dude to talk
to on on saturday nights 10 p.m 10 p.m
until we get it in tell them to tell
bing bing bing and it's over but um
canelo versus bevel it's gonna be a dope
fight you know you know what they should
know what they should do okay
no no i said you know what they should
do you know what the audience should do
they should order the fight mute the
fight and let you commentate it oh yeah
yeah
you should yeah i think that's it we
doing that we're doing that
they pull up we out here we running our
mouths we're talking we chat right
hey yo and you ain't got to come over
there and throw the flagship green
because i know you already paid for the
fight i already know you pay for your
drinks you saucy so i'll be reading the
chats i'll be getting in there
come through man come through 10 p.m
every saturday night
when it's mma it's gonna get really red
it's funny
when i set up the uh directory for last
week i didn't know i i just said it for
nine because i thought that i knew it
came out at 10 but i didn't know if it
was 9 30 and i didn't know we wanted to
go live i post kickstarter why'd you
post nine man it starts at 10. i'm like
do you i'm sitting here in my building
i'm putting my die in my bed i'm like
what the hell is going on it's not like
it starts automatically you have to
press go live so like
that's just one of those things that's
like
come here in this chat at this time
and then when you click live that's when
it goes live
so and my intro wasn't playing i'm like
what the hell brian's reviews it's this
channel king has his own
uh
his own little show every uh time
there's a fight that he wants you see
how he belittled me
like that
he's got his own he's got his own show
on here uh for whenever there's a fight
he wants to cover that's pretty much
like you're doing ufc boxing i'm not
doing anything that people put hands on
people yeah so
you're probably gonna see him if there's
nothing going on i'm going out in the
street number kids two bums
and they're gonna fight over a chicken
wing
it will be on this show on this channel
that you're currently watching this
brian it'll be uh saturday at
9 30 to 10 p.m that's usually when
you're going to be called bumps for
break
it's not bumps for bread but it's it's
combat talk so definitely it'll be live
king
king no that's gonna be the night there
ain't no fights if it ain't no fight
song
king is very stubborn when it comes to
uh because i would prefer him to do it
on discord for that because i can easily
drag people over to his channel uh but
that's that's besides the point you know
we're gonna do a whole lot of stuff with
whatever everybody works is gonna work
yeah we might talk about that make it a
little bit easy for everybody but
hustle
where do people find you
well y'all can find me here i am
currently playing kingdom hearts i'm
having a hell of a time i'm getting lost
but i'm still having going into the
why am i not killing this big dog in the
hercules i'm like what the three-headed
dog why am i what's going on hustle i
think you you need to be level 40 before
you oh let me check my level you know
what never mind um hey i do want to say
something on a more serious note well
before that thank you king for joining
us once again it's always a pleasure to
take it with you uh blaze you know
that's my boy right there um it's always
a blessing to kick it with blaze and you
know the rgt podcasts and so on and
stuff off um hey on a serious note if
you are getting up there in age please
go to the doctor get yourself checked
out get your physicals every year
i may or may not have sleep apnea i'm
not sure i don't got a problem sharing
that with nobody you know is what it is
everybody got it
yeah i know but good man but i'll be
struggling boy um but no no but just
it'd be hard to get oh my god but no no
just everybody go get yourself together
just make sure you take care of yourself
i know we kick it we have fun and games
and then stream all the time
but just please you know for your loved
ones for yourself just go get yourself
together because you know or if you feel
like checking out just go ahead and do
your debauchery go ahead don't bother
nobody take nobody with you
just go eat your overloaded pizzas your
overloaded sandwiches
make sure you go glove some oatmeal
cheese and just take it down but don't
bother nobody while you're doing it do
it alone don't oh my god
i i i can't co-sign that message good
lord you guys are homeless all right all
right
thank y'all thank you i love y'all man i
appreciate it oh my god
king is just crazy they're ruining that
moment just don't be bothered with
people while you're eating your snacks
so
remember guys
1 p.m sunday we're having a nice guest
on you know we're gonna have a good show
but we got a lot of little stuff to talk
about you know it's crazy king that
score evening stuff happened the day
after iop the day yeah
so we're gonna be talking about that uh
yeah we're gonna be talking yeah that
kind of what's funny is i woke up i i
was at my girl's house i woke up and i
looked at my phone
and then i see messages in there and i
was like yo let me call and see what's
going on and then i look that was sent
seven hours ago
so uh you know appreciate everyone
coming through definitely be on the iop
this sunday 1 p.m go there you know what
the lord's going to be saying we're
going to talk about some nice nice stuff
and until next week when we do our xbox
prediction show with me hustle and
gaming forte and probably two to three
other people we'll see you next week
we're out of here all right
till next time try to stay in the
daylight